if it's hitting front page news then
it's something people care about and
it's almost always negative yeah and
fearmongering if you're trying to gain
audience and gain influence and spread
this message it's harder to take a
positive story and get people to care
about it than to take a negative story
and put a positive spin on it and teach
people how to critically think solution
finding ways to do that like what you
just mentioned is key it's key for us to
reach people so then it's just you're
picking which negative and the bigger
the negative the bigger the audience you
can build and impact you can reach the
smaller the negative the small of the
audience that's powerful yeah right so
just finding bigger negatives
yeah all right so I'm here with Mike new
member of Mastermind as part of that we
do a one-on-one so what's on your mind
man how can I help oh I'm happy to be
here brother and um looking forward to
learning from you and the other movement
makers we are starting a brand new
channel called the positive Network and
uh we're we're looking to grow from
literally nothing to uh affecting people
all over the world with our message I
love I was your first subscriber yes you
sent the channel Nina sent it over it's
like zero subscribers and one video like
okay I'm I'm the first subscriber I'm
the first comment on your one short so
it's great the Great Beginnings yeah
yeah and it's um we're really looking
forward to it I mean we built multiple
companies um recently had a couple exits
and um we're kind of at the position now
you know after you've helped yourself
your family and those near you you then
have the ability to help a wider
audience and more people and so that's
where we find ourselves today and um you
know we live our life in a certain way
and what it comes down to is we're big
Believers in critical thinking and
self-sufficiency and we want to spread
that to the world because you know the
the message out there when it comes to
the positive Network there's a lot of
negativity out there according to the
sources of information that are coming
at us but the reality is we're just
shown the negativity there is an
overwhelming amount of amazing things
going on in the world and we need to
hear more of that we need to yeah talk
about the problems but then we need to
talk about the solutions to those
problems if they actually affect you in
your life so how do you see the content
playing out I mean it's beginning you
had at least one video when I saw and
maybe I don't know if you created any
sense but what's the thought process now
at least for videos the plan so we have
planned out to uh introduce the positive
Network talk about the Sovereign Life
operating system so the 12 points of
sovereignty that we're going to teach
and talk about uh my partner Andrew and
I uh Andrew for manic he started one of
the first YouTube free YouTube
instructional piano channels he's got
over half a million subscribers
brilliant gentlemen I praise him over
and over just genius level individual
who can still hold a conversation which
is rare um if you're having a having a
chat with him so we're going to co-host
the the main podcast vodcast and then
we're going to have a couple other shows
I'm going to interview people around the
world people are producing food for
themselves people who teach people about
data security um people who teach
children people who like all of the
aspects of The Sovereign Life operating
system doing a interview process and we
be doing the the one-on-one podcast and
that's that's where we're going to start
so I'm looking forward to your input on
you know I know you teach people how to
monetize and and uh you know build a
brand and a channel so that they can
quit their job well in our case we can
take a little bit more of a methodical a
long-term approach and we're looking to
build this right for the people that
we're serving yeah so I mean you
normally we'd start with a bis Dev show
which is like what are you trying to
sell and then let's bring guests on so
that you can you can create
relationships that help you sell more of
the thing for you you've got a longer
window so we going right to build in a
brand which is great takes longer to
build but you you've got more patience
because you've exited your company
when we talked over the the past week
you said you have 12 different kind of
areas or buckets of things that you talk
about Y and then the podcast is it going
to hit multiple areas are you going to
discuss current events like what's the
idea with the podcast on its own so the
podcast will be Andrew and I diving into
those 12 points of sovereignty and I'll
just summarize them they start with uh
Sovereign time then food Mind Body money
children relationship ships data defense
culminating in the 10th point which is a
sovereign citizen which allows us then
to change Sovereign governance and
rebuild Sovereign Nations there it is I
like it yeah and so we take the word
sovereign and we we have Rec coined it
to s o vrn Sovereign first reason is
because very few people can spell
sovereign I know I can't spell it
properly but also we need to get away
from the definition of sovereign being
kings queens leaders you know monarchy
in the old adage of the word and recoin
it to becoming a personal Sovereign
taking control of your life so that you
can provide for your family you can
provide for your neighbor eventually
your community and then your nation and
that comes from building up your
self-confidence and
self-sufficiency and if you look at if
you've never heard of maslov's hierarchy
of needs the base level is to have a
roof over your head to have food and
water to have security right to have
family and once those things are taken
care of and they can't be threat
threatened by anyone else then you can
help others and then you can build upon
that toward towards
self-actualization and so if we can
remove some of the biggest points of
fear in people's lives which is right
now things are things are a little rough
in North America and around the world
now buying food can be 50 to 100% more
expensive right now people are looking
at their homes costing double when they
go to renew their mortgages in the next
couple years and so the very base level
level of security is being threatened
and and that allows all sorts of
information to be put into your head
when you're in a state of fear and so I
really want to be out there my partner
and the partners of the channel want to
be out there and giving people hope
giving them practical applicable things
that they can do to to keep their family
safe have you made the first episode of
the podcast yet uh I have it uh have it
mapped out I had a little bit of jet lag
between Phoenix to here so I I will have
it recorded tonight and on the channel
oh so you're going to record it tonight
I'm going to record it tonight it's
going to be messy okay great I like it
we have something to look at tomorrow
good okay and so that so it's just going
to be you then just me yeah and then
Andrew and I will be on as soon as I'm
back we have a bunch of episodes lined
up and so how do you see an episode
first off how many do you see going you
solo versus you and Andrew so Andrew and
I are going to run weekly episodes um
yeah and that's going to be just
generally on all of the things we're
talking about it's going to be thought
leadership us diving into a particular
situation or problem that we see people
asking questions about having a
discussion about it but always ending on
a solution or something that someone
could apply so there's so many people
out there talking about the problems in
the world but not enough discussion on
what you might be able to do about it
okay so it's not going to be you know
fear this and fear that this is what's
wrong it's going to be highlighting
something that that is a problem and
then getting to a solution okay so
that's you and Andrew once a week then
also we want to do uh what you were uh
training us on the bizdev platform is I
have many many contacts from
intelligence Counter Intelligence food
Growers uh Health experts Experts of the
Mind experts with children experts in
relationships data defense and
interviewing them on what they do and
how they can help people out and there's
expertise like we're going to
crowdsource the expertise of the world
to help the average person apply things
in the order that they can but you're
not trying to sell anything no no okay
so usually bis is an interview but it's
trying to build a relationship so we
have a Business Partnership here you're
still just building brand you're not
you're not trying to sell anything to
them or Their audience you're just
trying to create your community and give
information yeah maybe you can give me
feedback on this bizdev how I see it is
audience sharing so some of these people
have large audiences they have
followings we want to reach Their
audience and they're going to want to
reach ours right now I mean you're one
of our only subscribers there's not much
that we can share but I've developed
strong relationships these people I've
connected them with other people in
other fields and um and so we're just
going to we're going to work together
towards that and then are you having a
third show of you solo or Andrew Solo or
that's so the third show that my wife
and I have been talking about is because
there's 12 points we could have a show
on everyone but what we think is we'll
start with something called Sovereign
children we raise our kids in a very uh
specific way that has worked really well
for us and we thought we would focus in
on kids and um and just teach people
what we're doing have some discussion
talk about that it's it's uh just to see
which one of these points strikes Accord
the most with people and we dive deep on
that okay so I mean I love it having
having 12 buckets can be hard to stay
consistent onh but maybe I think what we
talked about if you put them into like
buckets of four or something or buckets
of three and then staying consistent on
making sure that if you're making three
videos a week that each one of them is
hit each of those buckets is hit every
week because the challenge is if you go
and build an audience say the children
one takes off right so you start
building all these people who care about
Sovereign kids Sovereign kids Sovereign
kids they don't necessarily want the
other stuff yet Y and so then when you
post something else they don't watch
it's like oh I I thought this was a
kids's Channel yeah and so if you do
like through two months of sovereign
kids and then you pivot to two months of
growing your own food like oh then the
kids be like oh the Channel's switched
and then people come in for the food but
then they don't want the kid and so like
whatever the main buckets are you want
to try to stay consistent on hitting
them consistently right so if you have a
maybe a weekly show is like a weekly
Cadence is too too ambitious um but if
you know every two weeks if you hit all
four buckets or all 12 things somehow
every two weeks then the people who are
coming are used to the variety and they
know that next week there's going to be
another video for me even if I don't
have kids yet I don't care about the
kids maybe in the future but I'm not I'm
not consuming that yet or my kids are
growing up and like they're 18 and
they're out of the house I don't care
about this stuff right uh now my son is
14 so I probably care about what you're
GNA post
but but I'm okay with staying on the
channel because I know that the next
video is going to be interesting for me
yeah I I like that and maybe uh I I can
share this with those 12 points most of
them are interdependent on each other so
as someone goes through learning about
the Sovereign Life operating system and
say they focus on time first if that's
if that's where they want to want to
focus if they free up a little bit of
time that also allows them to say okay
well now I'm going to focus a little bit
more on the money side of thing if they
free up money well then that allows them
to free up you know a little bit more uh
work on their mind and their body and so
every person is going to come into this
with their own set of circumstances
their own uh availability of time their
own Financial picture and they're going
to choose okay I'm going to I'm going to
go after this this to me is the lwh
hanging fruit I I have whatever that
they perceive to be their hold back I'm
going to focus on this and so as we're
talking about each of these points we
actually reference a lot of the other
points there's a lot of interconnects
maybe you can give me feedback is that a
good thread between them all as we're
working through them for sure 100% just
being mindful
of if you're if you're only talking
about health and body for example for
two months and you make references to
other stuff but you're really just
building an audience about people who
care about health and body right but
then if you start introducing grow your
own
food I it kind of connects to health
because now I get my own organic food
but I may not be down that path too much
right and then I want the other stuff so
like we we need to create a consistent
schedule where you're Direct L hitting
the main points y gotcha okay within
each direct Point you're going to be
indirectly pointing to the other ones
but you don't want to have a month go by
and you haven't directly hit one of the
points right because the people who came
for that now feel left out yes and maybe
not subscribe or like stop watching the
videos CU like oh he doesn't talk to me
anymore yeah he's off topic yeah
according to that individual right that
makes sense and I may care a little bit
about the other side but I really care
about this and so if I know that you're
not making that anymore why am I going
to keep watching your videos gotcha cuzz
you think of it as this holistic thing
which is great most people will come in
for the thing they care the most about
and then they'll slowly learn about the
other things like oh yeah okay huh right
but if they're not getting their thing
then they probably bounce that makes
sense and then even for my wife and I
while we've developed many of these
points our current focus is mind and
body and so that's where we're diving in
and we're consuming information so I can
relate to that so so if your wife and
you you start a show and it's about kids
how you raise your kids and that's a
weekly show great so that's one of your
you know 12 pillars and then say like
you and Andrew can't connect and you
don't do your podcast for three weeks or
whatever and then you forget to do the
other that just basically like you and
your wife doing the kid show right then
again we start attracting an audience is
like oh we're growing but then now when
you go back to podcast with Andrew it's
like oh who are these guys yeah and the
views don't aren't there anymore the
people who loved it now they're not
coming back so we want to try to create
shows and say consistent on the themes
so that every month all of them are
being directly talked about right yeah
which is sometimes hard when there's 12
but at least if it falls into
buckets like health and mind can be in
the same general bucket so 10 11 and 12
citizen governance and Nation those
aren't going to have a ton of of talk
time they're going to be referenced but
they they're not the personal points
that people will be developing so one
way to look at is it's the first nine
and it would probably even though we
have we don't have our businesses
anymore we don't have any commitments
doing nine shows a week would be uh
overly ambitious no I wouldn't do n not
going to happen right with because
there's still there's still the business
to build out behind it and the support
for all the members but if those nine
can be bucketed to groups of three like
we talked about yeah then then you could
do one on
each right and again I I said weekly
might be a little ambitious
but even if every two weeks if every two
weeks it was something on one of those
three things then at least I see a
consistent theme coming in where if the
kids content is now like 60% of the
content that goes up and the other eight
things are all split between the other
times it's easy just go after what's
convenience right it's like oh my wife
sah we can do it together this easy I
can go film it and we have content and
we need to put something up on the
channel and lose sight of the fact that
strategically we're shifting our
audience towards this and we're
alienating the audience who cares about
else yeah maybe we can talk about
formulating the the process here I
wonder if Andrew and I talk about time
data and defense and that's a thing that
we hit on on our weekly podcast and my
wife and I do uh food children and
relationships and then the next show is
about the other three points and maybe
that's the Cadence three shows a week
touching on all those things how does an
audience view that if they know that
they're and then maybe timestamp this is
where we're going to talk if someone's
got a DE deep interest in the children
part they can just go to that piece and
get their fill each week you know their
their the new information new ideas like
how would you do that yeah would started
around the guests because they're the
hardest to book and the topics will be
kind of all over the place okay you
might say I want to talk about Sovereign
Nation but you your guest may not be
able to come on for three months M yeah
you and Andrew and you and your wife
have a more flexible like okay we got to
record something like you you're gonna
record something tonight so you have's
go to the basement let's yeah right like
you can't do that with a guest last
minute find some great guests to talk
about growing your own food yeah so it
starts with the guests and we have your
list of Ideal people that you're trying
to book and get on and and when they do
great that's the guest spot for the week
and then you and Andrew and you and your
wife kind of play
around whatever the guest talked about
so the guest talked about kids you don't
need another episode talking about kids
with your wife y that week gotta you shi
let's talk about mind and health and
same thing if the guest talks about
whatever you're going to talk about with
Andrew okay this week we're not going to
talk about this so you rotate around
what the guest is going to bring to the
table right okay and then as you're
delivering that to the audience you're
making sure that in your your thumbnail
and your description you're like this
this topic is on Sovereign mind so that
they know which which part you're
talking about at that point in time
whether they want to check in or not
yeah I would constantly
reinforce what Sovereign is y like
there's 12 parts to live in a sovereign
life and even if you list them off
quickly and today we're talking about
Sovereign blank okay so that I know that
there's Sovereign Life and then in the
description could' be ideally some kind
of lead magnet where we're leading
people you have a PDF on how to live a
Sovereign Life yeah and you whether it's
a PDF or a video you explain what the 12
steps are and a quick thing about each
one uh and then you capture emails in
exchange for the PDF so now we're
building a list so that when you get
some big guest on we want to tell our
email list hey go watch the new video we
just dropped right you have a community
that you're building because community
building on on the platforms is hard
there's no real community on Instagram
or Twitter or uh YouTube or like there's
comments but they're not really
connected Community is what you bring
bring off yeah so any post that you make
won't automatically go to your whole
audience but if you have a email list
and there's something big that you want
to promote eventually when you launch
your book and your whatever you know you
have an email list to be able to go off
and if that's part of the plan that's
what Publishers want the most is email
list gotcha so right away so we're
talking about what there 12 STS to
deliver in a Sovereign Life boom boom
boom boom boom uh and if you want the
free pdf you know it's in the
description below today we're talking
about how to Blink yeah so I know I know
it's I know what it's talking about for
the one with Andrew it'd be interesting
if you're following the news at all I
don't know how much you pay attention to
the news and what's going on that whole
there's so much negativity we want to
bring a positive angle and then always
end with the strategy or hope of like
not just saying it could be better but
teaching them how to do it yes it's
great to make those kinds of things
culturally relevant okay meaning you're
commenting on something in the news and
then you take some big news story that's
happening and then you put you run it
through the lens of sovereign and a 12
steps and then you give me action items
or homework that makes sense um and we
we don't watch the news like we we stay
we like we'll get a rundown of a couple
things that are going on but we try to
stay as far away from traditional media
as we can but that makes sense where the
people that we're trying to reach may
still be consuming all of this stuff and
what's what's a story recently that you
know something about oh dude you'd have
to you'd have to let me know I I keep it
so far away from my mind it's not even
funny well okay what do that mean not be
a fit but if you're looking at um you
know I don't know your thoughts on our
prime minister
yeah let's stay away from that one
yeah too controversial yeah yeah well
well but that that brings up like that I
mean that becomes part of it right like
can you comment on something or if
you're talking about people going to you
just mentioned people going to have
double their interest rates on their
mortgage yeah I mean so that's a
statistic like that came from somewhere
and that there you go okay so yeah I do
follow that in the news and the
statistics that are are are coming out
on the mortgages that are going to be up
for renewal in 2024 and 2025 right and
for a lot of people that that's going to
be really devastating combined with the
the cost of food the cost of fuel the
cost of utilities so you you heard about
that somewhere you read about it
somebody sent you an article yeah do you
remember how you heard about it I think
I just follow that sort of stuff because
I'm I'm I follow a lot of financial
stuff and so like a a Global Mail one
one of my passions is real estate
probably something like that yeah okay
so like Global Mail for the you know us
audience is one of our national
newspapers in Canada but you're going to
talk about American things too so Global
Mail New York Times or whatever says
this right so that could be the start of
the podcast it's like you read off a
headline and you show the screenshot of
the website to say look at this New York
Times says mortgages are going to be
double an interest rate in the next
three to five years or whatever the
headline is uh and then the article
itself will be all about panic and scare
tactics and fear and give Zero Solutions
are practical right so even you have the
headline and then a quick reaction to
what you're reading and then and then
your reaction to it is like hey this is
fear mongrain that makes a ton of sense
and then which of the 12 things is just
fall under and then take me to the
positive side let's go to some solutions
and and then what do I do about it it's
like okay this is a negative thing
happening but there's a positive upside
and here's what it looks like and if you
want to not have to pay that or if you
want to find your way out if you want to
have Financial Freedom or be Sovereign
in your finances here are some of the
things that people like you should do I
like that a lot yeah and then you so
you're like your
framework uh is how you see the world
like it's how you make decisions for
your life for your family for your
business you're making decisions that
allow you to live a sovereign life as
you define it and then you're trying to
give that to others not just being
positive but also having sharing how we
problem solve so we we we have a situ we
have situations come up in our lives all
the time some are are difficult some are
frustrating so to your point look at the
situations that many people are facing
that are current and relevant and then
walk through the almost externally the
internal discussion that happens or the
discussion between Tina and I or some
friends of ours in an irrelevant space
and then my life has been about solving
problems and it'll give insight to how
we think about things how we go through
it and it may not be the perfect solve
for the individual watching us but it'll
show them how we think about it and they
can adapt and think about it in their
own way specific to their circumstances
I like that a lot your principles are
Timeless M the idea of of being you know
Sovereign financially is a is a Timeless
from now it's in 100 years is still
relevant 100 years ago is still relevant
how you do it will change and so you
have to apply it through a filter of a
story and the bigger the story is
the more you become culturally relevant
and you're saying hey here's a different
way to see this problem yes instead of
the negativity and fear mongrain and
hopelessness that's out there here's a
way to shape this into something
positive for your life yeah so you can
take something from your life you can
say how you raise your kids uh or
whatever is happening on your property
you know like you know what how do you
feed the pigs or how do you I mean I
don't know whatever problems you're
facing but like those are those are
great stories but they're small cuz I
may not have kids that are the same age
as you or I may not have pigs on my
property or like those are Niche versus
something that is hitting mainstream
right now yeah that you can spin
positive it's how you go from a small
audience to a much bigger one to then
it's like okay so he's talking about
mainstream things but he's making it in
a positive way so I'm now not as scared
about these things that are popping up
yeah he's teaching me how to reframe
some of these things so I can see the
world more positively when I get hit
with negativity from mainstream Media or
my friends or my family or whatever
you're teaching me different way to
think right it's an operating system for
thinking and problem solving so it's a
skill set you're teaching me how to
critically think instead of just
reacting to all the things being thrown
at me and then you're giving me
Solutions so you're not just teaching me
how to think through a problem you're
telling me what I can do to solve this
problem in my own life yeah right if you
apply that to something big like oh my
God my mortgage rate is going to go up I
can't I don't even know what to do now
you become like the trusted place that I
want to get all of my information from
so you may not have a POV on everything
that's happening in the world and I
don't want to turn you into a News
Junkie just for this right it's like
what are you already consuming that
might make sense um you know if you see
some headline about uh kids mental
health is at an all-time high or
something right like kids are suicidal
at at the highest rate ever or whatever
right okay you have well it's
interesting you say that and and in
individual or small group conversations
we have with people where they present
something that is frustrating them or or
is causing some fear in their life or
some analysis paralysis each one of
those situations I'll dive in with the
person and just start this creative idea
process of like well how how could this
be done differently or have you heard of
this or have you have you seen this
resource or this book or this individual
they lay out all these steps to solve
this problem and so what you're framing
is take things that are largely shared
by a large group of people
or a set of articles that have been
written to make people afraid for
whatever outcome or whatever purpose
part part of critical thinking is why
was this article written first and
foremost does this article actually have
anything to do with me or am I buying
into General I'm like I'll have people
come to me and say hey uh you know
mortgages are going through the roof
everyone's going to where is where's
your rate oh I'm at I locked in just
before all of this crazy Financial stuff
happened I'm good for five more years
right there was like okay so you're good
but if a pro person actually has that
problem then we'll dive in and you know
we'll we'll work on it so if we can take
your advice and look at that broad
spectrum then we can help a lot of
people um without approach I mean if
it's hitting front page news then it's
something people care about yeah and
it's almost always negative yeah and
fear mongrain was the last time story
hit the first page it sells ads yeah
well it has eyeballs bleeds the leads
all of that stuff right but you know you
could take one approach of you're only
going to highlight positive stories but
then it's on you to it's if you're
trying to gain audience and gain
influence and spread this message it's
it's harder to take a positive story and
get people to care about it than to take
a negative story and put a positive spin
on it and teach people how to critically
think it's solution and you you hit it
right on the head Our intention is not
to be rah rah everything is great in the
world it literally is to turn the
negative into a positive and so finding
ways to do that like what you just
mentioned is key it's key for us to
reach people so then it's just your
picking which negative and the bigger
the negative the bigger the audience you
can build and impact you can reach yeah
the smaller the negative the smaller the
audience that's powerful yeah right so
just finding bigger negatives yeah so
you know whether you talked about the
vaccine during Co whether you talk about
the election cycle that's coming up in
the US whatever the things are that you
care about and you're willing to share
prime
minister that's actually not a big one
right like your audience is in Canada
right so you talking about our prime
minister whether you hate him love him
why how to problem solve how to fix the
next election whatever y it won't get
you tons of impact because it's only the
Canada yeah you talk about the US
election coming up it's going to have a
much bigger impact yeah and for now like
our hope is to reach the
English-speaking world because that's
that's that's our ability to reach you
can even take a stance of um even if you
don't want to be critical or political
right like uh is Biden too old to run
right you don't you you don't you might
have strong views on Biden that you may
or may not want to share but you could
flip it in a positive way to say okay so
this is a concern it's like you know we
want we want our leaders to be healthy
so how do you live a healthy life into
your 80s 90s hundreds and you flip it
into a health article yeah without you
saying Biden is like the worst or
whatever you want to right so you're
taking it in a different way yeah and I
mean I mean in the political Spectrum I
I I don't I won't we won't talk about it
a ton because the you know with politics
there's typically somebody you know
supporting that politician that has
policies that they you know they're in
place because certain people supported
them so no politician is coming to save
you nobody's going to write a policy to
you know help your family in any
meaningful impactful way if you're
sitting there waiting for somebody to
come and save you it it's not going to
happen at least it's not going to happen
in any way that will be super
significant we've seen that throughout
history and and so the positive Network
in The Sovereign Life OS operating
system is you taking charge by you
learning about strategies and methods
that apply to you yeah and taking back
your life you take
responsibility you know if you do that
then you can help the next person you
can spread that to the next person and
the next person The Genius of humanity
is already out there we're crowdsourcing
and compiling it and delivering it to
people on a platform so they can solve
their lives in each unique puzzle that
is an individual's life you know Lex
fredman I do yeah he's got a great
podcast um he's super long long episode
well that's another thing the longer you
go the better okay it's great as long as
it's valuable like don't but don't cut
it short if you're on a if you're on a
good good role trajectory yeah you could
go long Rogan long Freedman long like
everybody's Ultra long is crushing if
you have something to say but one of my
favorite episodes he um he was talking
about Elon Musk versus Zuckerberg and
they were going to do a boxing match or
a UFC fight or whatever right and happen
but who's gonna win everybody's focused
on who's gonna win musk is bigger but
he's older he's got he's taller but he's
slower like all the like dissecting who
would win yeah and he talked about the
fact that he's he's glad that both of
them are learning martial arts because
in martial arts it teaches discipline it
teaches self-reflection yeah it teaches
empathy it teaches compassion she's
taken in a completely different so
they're being they're being goofy and
getting the views but then they're teach
teaching something well everybody else
is focused on who's going to win the
fight yeah and he's taking this
mainstream thing that everybody was like
for a while everybody was talking about
so that's the news thing you're talking
about yeah and he flips it to say here's
why martial arts is so valuable and I
hope they learn a lesson I'm so glad
that they're doing this because I hope
they pick up these things by studying
martial arts he just takes you in a
completely different direction but it's
but if he's just talking about martial
arts who cares doesn't matter like it's
the fact that it's culturally relevant
right now cuz he's a Jitsu expert Lex
right so he could talk about it during
his day-to-day podcast but it doesn't
matter because it's not cultur relevant
but as soon as Mark and uh uh Elon are
going to fight now it's cultur relevant
attached to that but instead of him just
saying I think Mark's going to win
because he has better Judit he's just
taking a completely different direction
he like
huh I like how he thinks right like
that's my favorite thing that he's ever
said yeah because he took a POS he took
a negative thing everybody's freaking
out about and gossip and whatever and
turn it into a life lesson and
positivity so like you have those
opportunities where I said like is Biden
too old you don't have to go in on he's
too old he's not too old but you flip it
to how do we increase the longevity of
our leaders how do you increase your
longevity as well exactly even if if you
want to go and Destroy Biden you can but
you don't even have to dive into that
just go into like your health is
actually your access to time more hours
in the day more years in your life right
and that's a that's an evergreen message
but we're tying it to a news story which
is Biden's too old y brilliant if people
want to find you where they going uh
head to our YouTube channel the positive
Network and be one of the first
subscribers and we're going to get going
on this journey I love it Mike vaultz
cheers brother appreciate it to watch me
coach another Mastermind member
oneon-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I like trying to figure out how do
I make $2,000 a month 2,000 a month I'll
need 2,000 per client if you could make
2,000 a month per client or you have you
know basically $88,000 coming in every
month you basically have a six figure
business